Brandel Chamblee of the golf channel
joining me here to wrap up this Friday's
show and actually preview a live
sporting event how about that Brandel
I'm tickled pink about it thanks for
having me on rich nice talk about some
real of sports real great right how
about this I'm gonna this is great
Christopher are you ready for this I'm
gonna set that how this is a real sports
question how does the course set up for
the participants
I can't stream Ozarks or house of cards
anymore yeah how does it set up I mean
that's a big unknown I mean this is one
of the most mysterious and I think
reputable golf clubs in the world think
of Augusta National having never hosted
the Masters that's kind of what we're
talking about here with this golf course
but I think Rory's probably the most
familiar with it his father's a member
and these great friends with the
president there Jimmy Dunn so I'm sure
Rory's played at the best but it's a
it's a wide-open venue basically but
with a lot of just diabolical sort of
green complexes so I think you know
given the fact that three of the guys in
the foursome of some of the longest
hitters in the game and then Ricky's
probably although not short probably one
of the best if not the best putter in
the game so this could be like an
all-out brawl it could be like the
equivalent of pool sharks having
trickshot contests
it could be a hell of a lot of fun to
watch well I'm looking forward to that
and which which team do you think has
the advantage going in that's enough
that's another sports question um this
is right on paper Rory and Dustin I mean
you're talking about who the most
dominant players the last 30 years only
two players have held the number one
spot in the world longer than Rory and
only four players fail the number one
spot in the world longer than DJ but
then I think you know the ardent golf
fan knows Matt Wolff but I think those
that are tuning in and there'll be a lot
of those I think that don't are not that
familiar with the game of life right I
think they're gonna be absolutely have
their mind blown by the swing of Matt
Wolff it is the most maybe the most
unusual golf swing professional golf has
ever seen but he swings the club at
about 125 miles an hour so if you're a
baseball
fan this is like Chad Bradway go on it
as fast as Nolan Ryan that that's what
we're gonna see here like this crazy
funky action where you see it you're
gonna go what the hell was that
how do I do that and you know and it's
because he swings so hard and Dustin
hits it so far and Laurie it's so far it
could be a lot of you know a lot of
trash talk and a lot of catch that you
know I didn't catch that or so it should
be a lot of fun on top of being you know
I think pretty competitive Brandel
Chamblee of the golf channel here in the
Rich Eisen show again for those who may
not know about Seminole Golf Club you
obviously alluded to how how few times
it holds anything I'll give you the
floor and about this golf course and
what we're gonna see on Sunday well it's
known as a masterpiece of design by a
fella by the name of Donald Ross who
designed it oh my gosh 100 years ago and
it's it's known for its really difficult
green complexes and within the world of
golf course architects lovers some would
argue that it is the greatest second
shot golf course or the most difficult
second shot golf course in the world
because the greens are pitched sharply
back to front crown false fronts and
sides and the conditions are you know
tight fairways really you know
unpredictable winds so it's it's a it's
a very difficult golf course but looks
kind of easy but it'll be beautiful
because it's packed right hard against
the Atlantic and and I think you know
there's we're gonna hear the players
they're going to be mic'd up likely they
got to be some great exchanges and it
gives all the players sort of a chance
to show off well Donald Ross had some
awful evil things in his mind back in
the day when he was designing golf
courses Brandel on where there was a
Wampanoag golf course up and no West
Hartford which I was a laid out when I
was out of ESPN it was at Donald Ross
course the false fronts were absurd it
just absolutely it turned me into mush
by the end we all know Pinehurst is
another Donald Ross correct right that's
right you know I played the 99 US Open
at Pinehurst I drove it perfect every
day on the fifth hole I only had eight
iron in there every day and I never
hit the green and that's it you know I I
joked my caddy that I was harder to hit
than a tropical mosquito and that's and
that's the green complex is a dollar rot
through these perched up little greens
they look big enough but when you
actually get up there they're they're as
big as your kitchen you know I mean you
got to hit the perfect shot
shake the perfect way with the right
amount of span and the right trajectory
and then the very next hole you'll have
different winds because the holes move
around in different directions so it
will challenge and it does you know
challenge the best players very many
times you know you know when you walk
off the golf course you think I cannot
believe I just shot 77 or 78 look the
first time Arnold Palmer played there
back when he was a rookie right he was
just getting started on the tour he went
out he shot 87 mm-hmm he told his wife I
don't think I'm gonna go back out the
next day she said you can't do any worse
and he went out shot 88 give you some
idea of the difficulty of this golf
course even though it has never been
notoriously known as a long golf course
I mean it will play 7,200 yards of
change but not it's not going to
challenge these guys in length it'll
just challenge them and second shots and
shots around the green you sound chipper
man this is a golf event it's human
beings it's gonna be live we're gonna
watch it it's it's as you sound like
you're in a this is chipper Brandel
Chamblee this is great listen you know I
left the Players Championship March 13th
drove us back talked to my wife and I
said I don't know that we're gonna play
golf the rest of the year you know
because it just sounded the uncertainty
in the doom and gloom and making
allowances for the worst case scenario
so the idea that they're going to get
out and say you can responsibly get back
to playing golf without fans under the
right conditions you know golf is you
know it's a lot of fun but if you're a
professional golfer or professional
athlete
competition is addictive you know it's
nicotine and everybody in the game is
itching to light up right now and
everybody in sport is ditching to light
up it's like let's get back to competing
and try to make the best out of this and
compete safe and responsibly and then
you know the only one who's more chipper
is Chris Brockman my degenerate across
the way who's actually
with his friends your your your propping
and all that sort of stuff right do you
want to do you want you want to ask is
it Brandel Chamblee zextras I'm gonna
have you actual piece of Rhys lots of
questions here okay so we're talking
about the second hole what do you think
might say drive at the furthest on hold
oh my gosh well I think that I'd give
the edge to Matt wolf again Matt look
and swing upwards of 130 miles an hour's
and you know Rory is around 122 to 124
DJ's about the same although he hasn't
been as fast this year so I'd give I
mean I think Matt will surprise some
people you know these things are
notoriously hard to handicap because one
match plays given players of this skill
it's almost a toy a coin toss but then
players show up in these matches with
varying degrees of sort of intensity you
don't know whose practice you don't know
who hasn't so I think more than anything
this is going to be like the the
all-star game
you know guys are going to be showing
off and it's really the purpose that
yeah sure they're competing to win
there's pride at stake but really it's
just a race and entertaining people and
raise some money or an incredible cause
yeah of course that's well and good but
is it going to be a close match or do
you see this as a blow out one way or
the other I personally I think of 1718
years of trying to guess the winner of
Tour events I might have gotten to right
nice yes you're getting the wrong tree
what'd he say not right
and nobody's record is any better right
there are everybody's terrible but this
one can only go one of two ways so I
would definitely give the edge to Rory
in p/j you know they're there you know
there's number one players in the world
they both want to Vardon Trophy they
both hit at 9 miles they got the edge
there they got the edge in driving and
they got the edge and approach shot and
I think that'll be the difference this
is exciting
that's this bottom line
I'll give it to you
DJ there you go closest to the how you
said Matthew offers Wolf's got the
strangest swing of a professional golfer
that allowed you the the Barclays room
that you need to have in terms of a
swing Randall
yeah well we're talking professor those
Barclays owns that real estate it is for
the weirdest golf swing maybe in the
history of the game but in professional
golf and there's been some weird ones
Jim Furyk Lee Trevino a brewer but Matt
Wolfe
well way do you see maybe you've already
seen it rich I'm sure you have but you
know it's it's unbelievably unique well
I can't wait to see it this weekend on
Golf Channel NBC nbcsn balls in the air
at 2:00 Eastern Time Randall thanks for
coming on the show we'll get you back on
maybe next week to preview the Tiger
Phil Brady paint Manning extravaganza -
you got there you go actual event actual
event
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here